justin steele jd yeah it's a forcing
fastball it's a sinker it's a slider
it's a curveball and rarely uses a
change up it's kind of odd for a
left-handed pitcher to not have a change
up you think he would ultimately develop
that and help him compete against
right-handed hitters because he's been
nails on lefties they're hitting just a
buck 11 against them but righties have
had their way with justin and this is a
very deep very talented a right-handed
hitting cardinal lineup that he's up
against
and a swing and a miss and he gets
goldschmidt
so he punches out their hottest hitter
that one out to short horner to bodhi
onto schwendell
6-4-3 and they turn it nicely
good job by justin steele pitching
around the lead-off single here come the
cubs up to hit no score those are the
season numbers for jay happ
today his tenth start wearing the birds
on the bat four and two is a cardinal
43 and two-thirds innings he's allowed
two earned or less and six of his nine
starts with the cardinals and is hyundai
pitch arsenal yeah you talk about being
consistent look the four-seam fastball
we know he likes to run it up run it run
it in the two-seam fastball you see the
numbers there he's been really
consistent and even out of those seven
out of nine he's allowed three or less
so that's complete consistency
pretty good numbers that's drilled right
center field that's gonna touch down and
bang up against the wall
and schwendell into second it's 12 in a
row that keeps that hitting streak alive
and takes care of it early here
this afternoon and figured he'd be a
good matchup with jay happs 19 teams in
that club that you don't want to be
associated with and they add to it
elevated the fastball and a strikeout
the one-two
fastball again and struck him out
back-to-back case for half
coming up nolan orenado followed by
carlson and sosa
and i turn around
sosa is down on strikes
and i
i'm just sitting here doing
doing my work
what he has accomplished and what he's
done this year it's been pretty amazing
so thanks for stopping by wayne
appreciate it great job there by justin
steele
as bader is down on strikes no score
middle to second
it's softly
bare-handed
and out at first
oh my goodness again nolan ornato
do or die bare-handed play
and another defensive gem
for the saint louis cardinals third
baseman
oh my goodness it's not that easy
goldschmidt is hitting 347 against
left-handed pitching this year struck
out his first time up the 2-2
with the drive out to center
gone
goldie
30.
two to nothing
st louis
and now has driven in 95.
so with about a week to go he's got a
chance at a hundred rbi season two to
nothing cardinals
2-2 pitch and he struck him out
so strikeout number four for half
hit 150 and then is taking off here with
the cubs 0-2 pitch
edmond spins is it two
got him double play
the defense again for st louis on
display
[Applause]
edmond sosa goldie in a four six three
double play
can you believe bias walk rate since he
get traded to the match what is going on
[Laughter]
why did he do that in chicago
two down bases empty steal at 1-1 it
hits softly with duffy in
he throws him out and a 1-2-3 inning for
justin steele
and the 3-0 by half
and the base is loaded two walks in the
inning and four today for j out mike
maddox hops out of the st louis dugout
to give whitley time to get loose you
got bodhi here and then the eighth place
hitter thompson
a 3-2 pitch
he got him it's a strikeout
and happ has five today none bigger than
that strikeout of david bode with the
bases loaded
and now there's two away and the one-two
pitch by half
he got him it's a strikeout back-to-back
case to end the threat
and better hits it out to deep left
and that ball is off the top of the ivy
and harrison racing to second base and
in there with a double
career hit number 300 for harrison bader
it's a double and a line shot
off the brick and the ivy of the left
field wall at wrigley
[Applause]
i think he was expecting the express
there and he got to local
rondon has had a couple of big hits
coming off the bench
rondo
into left
off the bench and a two-run homer
jose rondon
a pinch hit
two run shot
and the cardinals have the lead four
nothing
in the top of five
you know you're strong but and the
wind's blowing out a little bit when you
break your bat barry bonds it out of the
park the o2
lifted in the air out to left and out of
wrigley
that's how you do it for your 30th bomb
of the year
the cardinals now with three players
with 30 or more homers this season
the latest tyler o'neill
number 30.
oh no and that hits sosa on the wrist or
the hand
he's been hit a bunch this year
that's the 14th time he's been hit by a
pitch
and he went straight to the dugout and
that's
where
that's got your concern when he does
that
the 1-1 pitch to edmond
tommy a base head to left
here comes bader he'll score and that
makes it a seven nothing cardinal lead
o2 pitch
another one and a base hit into right
field drops in
and another run will score
that is neutral
edmond to third and the cardinals add on
it's eight nothing here in the top of
the sixth sergio is gonna hit
for nico horner
that's out to center going back is bader
looking god
his fourth of the year he just got it
into the basket in center field
and surge puts the charge into one the
cubs are on the board
and one now
center field bader started and it's over
his head
two runs gonna score roman into second
and it is eight four wow
that one ripped down the right side
fair ball
romaine coming in
and now it's 8-5 and giovanni gallegos
is in and the cardinals trying to make
it 13 wins
in a row the 2-2 pitch
he got him it's a strikeout
and it's lucky number 13.
second longest winning streak in
franchise history